i
[Música]
ah
esta noche se realizará el tan esperado
debate entre los dos candidatos a la
vicepresidencia de los eeuu el actual
vicepresidente mike pence por el partido
republicano y por el partido demócrata
kamala harris este debate se va a
realizar en la universidad de utah en
soul city no es coincidencia que se
realice allí ya que los dos partidos
buscan la atención de los votantes de la
costa oeste del país pero también del
voto joven y por eso se realizarán en
esta universidad se espera que sean 90
minutos sin interrupciones en donde los
dos puedan defender las plataformas de
sus principales candidatos a la
presidencia de los eeuu pero también se
esperan que el camarada harris ataque al
vicepresidente que tenga una estrategia
de ataque por la manera en la cual el
presidente de donald trump ha manejado
su enfermedad su diagnóstico por
coronavirus dejando la casa blanca e
invitando a que la gente no utilice
máscara y simplemente restando
importancia a este virus así que la cita
será a las 9 de la noche tiempo de la
costa este
eeuu
[Música]
con el anuncio del contagio de donald
trump por kobe 19 el debate dice
presidencial el único que habrá cobra
más importancia que nunca esta noche
kamala harris y el vicepresidente may
pen se enfrentarán en un cara cara de 90
minutos moderado por la directora de la
oficina en washington del usa today
susan page quien no ha querido filtrar
los temas pero seguramente kamala harris
tendrá que hacer una defensa de su
historial y del de by the end y mike
pence tendrá que defender la gestión que
se ha hecho de esta pandemia además de
las acciones del presidente desde que
fue diagnosticado positivo por kobe 19
esta vez habrá nueve segmentos de 10
minutos cada uno y cada candidato tendrá
2 minutos para hacer su exposición del
tema posterior habrá un pequeño debate
esta vez se han extremado las
precauciones sanitarias y ambos
candidatos estarán separados por una
barrera de plexiglás a petición de la
campaña de biden además cualquier
asistente que no utilice la mascarilla
dentro de la sala será acompañado a
abandonar el lugar todo en un guiño a la
familia trump que en el primer debate no
quiso utilizar la mascarilla
[Música]
y aquí en miami hay cierta expectación
por el debate vicepresidencial entre
mike pence y kamala harris especialmente
entre la comunidad latina que espera que
en esta ocasión se puedan abordar temas
de interés como la reforma migratoria o
los planes de salud para los próximos
cuatro años aunque la comisión de
debates presidenciales que organiza el
evento no ha dado a conocer más detalles
sobre el programa pero parece que las
extremas medidas de seguridad con la
instalación de placas plásticas para
proteger a ambos candidatos de el
coronavirus cobrarán un gran
protagonismo
de hecho el evento ha tomado cierta
relevancia porque no se sabe si podría
ser el último que se celebren según en
la agenda prevista tras esta cita habría
un nuevo debate presidencial programado
en el sur de la florida trump ya ha
dicho que tiene la intención de
participar presencialmente en el debate
a pesar de que aún se está recuperando
de el coronavirus joe biden por su parte
ha señalado que prefiere esperar a las
recomendaciones de los expertos de salud
para tomar una decisión al respecto
[Música]